hello you're watching GameSpot daily
where we covers 6 news stories in 30
minutes or less I'm Callie and I'm
joined by Michael Haim hi how's it going
I feel great today today every day is
great everybody's great at your jeunesse
yeah it's it's a weaboo Wednesdays so
I'm rocking it is we be Wednesday and I
I did watch the personify the enemy last
night in fact I did snap damn what did
you think real quick I um you know what
I think my thoughts are actually gonna
take longer so we could say that for the
end at the end of these winds they shows
we're gonna do a little Anime News anime
update yeah so y'all gotta stick around
for that but another one of my passions
is Nicki Minaj and we have some Nicki
Minaj oh yeah how fitting what's the
first story of the day then the first
story of the day is Nicki Minaj's new
song it's called chun-li this is a story
that I threw on the pile yesterday cuz I
was like it's jug Lee and and then we
didn't write it up but this comes from
pitchfork
so nicki is releasing two new songs look
leave this brief by the way she's
releasing two new songs tomorrow that's
Thursday and one of them was called
Chumlee Chumlee first appeared of course
in Street Fighter 2 in 1991 I do want to
show you her cool promotional image
which you know oh my god this image may
contain sensitive yeah might be
sensitive material so for all y'all out
there I guess um yeah there she is
you aren't you are a big fan of Nicki
Minaj I love Nicki Minaj okay okay
what's your what's your favorite Nicki
Minaj song I like feeling myself okay
that's I hate that sense it's never
saying that again all right all right
I've been more I think well real quick I
think there's there's always been like a
weave of video game and nerd culture in
hip-hop yeah absolutely
yeah and then now it's like it just it's
reaching higher and higher heights yeah
Drake actually was playing for tonight
last night Drake was playing for tonight
last night
you got like a lot of rap mentioned hey
Travis Scott playing for tonight too man
a lot of rap mentions Dragon Ball
specifically
yeah like seriously you can if you
search like Dragonball in rap there's
like videos on it analyzing it so yeah
that's your total like out of the
out-of-left-field story to warm up good
morning
so anyway on to the real real actual
real news story number two is oh yeah
it's not radical Heights which you may
have seen it launched yesterday radical
Heights has no female avatars at launch
is the latest thing this is it so don't
don't go in those comments and tell me
I'm mad cuz I'm not mad I actually wrote
this story and one of the things I said
about it was that this game is in
extreme or early access the most extreme
of early access is possible yeah and
therefore a lot of things are going to
be an unfinished but this is just
something to be aware of radical Heights
has it says female characters coming so
yes you can literally in the tab he says
crews choose your character you can
choose male and then the female one is
like great out saying coming soon I was
like okay you know that's that's fine
the so if you don't know we kind of
hinted at this but radical Heights is
the new battle royale game from
lawbreakers dev Bosque
that's the cliffy B joint and it did go
into early access yesterday so a lot of
people have been streaming it and
playing it well streaming it not well
people isn't playing it well you have to
play it to stream it exactly but the
devs did comment on some concerns on
Twitter and they also included that once
female characters are included in the
game you'll be able to wear all
cosmetics regardless of gender which is
pretty cool okay that's cool yeah yeah
radical Heights we're actually streaming
radical Heights after this show we are
so if we want to drop that promo that
hot promo right now your boy Eric Tay
will be streaming this with someone else
we're not sure yet afterward so you can
see how this game is in action I know
homeboy Alessandro is planet yesterday I
got a little taste of it as well late
yesterday and to say this is an early
access is an understatement I think yeah
like I was like a pre-alpha or something
but I mean the game works
it functions incomplete textures but you
know did you have fun playing it
sure all right well there you have it
that's radical Heights yeah I don't know
I think maybe I'm getting burnt out on
battle royale games that's true because
you are GameSpot's resident battle
royale expert call me mister battery all
over here that's what we call him no one
calls me that please don't call me that
y'all better not call me that evening
Michael mr. battle royale hi um that's
you that's your name anyway damn it um
this one I think is a little meteor oh
it's gonna take it now we got the wheel
so someone in the comments section
yesterday said this is like to fall of
you is he was on point was more Xbox
news okay sure and more anime news so
we're taking care of both of those today
you know what my dude we got you we got
you and we listened and you will have
been heard so we got some Xbox news we
got it we got a double we got a
doubleheader yeah we do so a bunch of
original Xbox games are becoming
backwards compatible on the Xbox one
this month and buy a bunch we mean a
bunch so during the latest episode of
inside Xbox Microsoft revealed the next
19 original Xbox games that will be
playable on the Xbox one and they are
the first original Xbox games to be
added since the initial batch last fall
hmm so if you are an OG xbox kid get
ready yes there there this month in
April there will be two phases in which
oh gee Xbox games will whoa whoa there
will be two phases in which original
Xbox games are going to be back compat
on the Xbox one so on April 17th let's
go back to back on this all right we got
blinks the time sweeper final yes yeah
break down conquer live and reloaded
which we are looking at right now if
you're watching the elder scrolls 3
morrowind yet yeah uh hunter to the
reckoning Jade Empire Panzer Dragoon
Orta and SSX 3 yeah though some dope
games I think I could line up actually
yeah I played I should ton of links by
the way yeah blinks was was it a launch
game oh but remember I was too young
back then but I do remember blinks on a
demo disc that much
no this is a yeah this is the successor
to mario now that that game did some
interesting things is it's cool for what
it was but cancer Dragoon Orta oh boy I
remember playing that yeah yes
that game is a rail shooter' and I think
it holds up all saundra actually has a
copy at his desk he's like I was snap I
could actually put and then we have so
that was the April 17th roll out April
26 also has games and there's one that's
gonna get us real there are real excited
actually a handful here it's April 26 is
like Star Wars day essentially so I will
run down April 26 Xbox original Xbox
games that aren't gonna be back and pad
for the Xbox one
all right Destroy All Humans full
spectrum warrior mercenaries playground
of destruction MX unleashed for Europe
only you get Panzer elite action fields
of glory yeah and we got some Star Wars
bangers here all right
Star Wars Battlefront Star Wars
Battlefront to the good ones the good
ones my bad
Star Wars Jedi Knight Jedi Academy Star
Wars Jedi Starfighter
US Star Wars Knights of the Old Republic
to the Sith Lords and Star Wars Republic
Commando oh dang
those are looking those are very good
games that I think still hold up today
especially Knights of the Old Republic
yeah
if you haven't played nice the Old
Republic what are you doing I don't it
come on man
yes but Star was nice to the Republic to
is on PC and it also had a revamp on
Steam which was not too long ago which
was kind of out of the blue but also
very much appreciated especially for
someone like me who loves that game he
loves all things Knights of the Old
Republic but um
yes Jedi and Knight Jedi Academy is on
there but I I don't know if Jon I - Jedi
Outcast
was and then was already back and pat
but anyway which is the but we have a
list on gamespot.com don't we do but uh
yeah
Jedi Knight is the third-person kind of
action shooter hybrid if you're not
familiar with the series dating back to
the 90s on PC
Xbox versions are pretty good so if you
don't if you haven't dipped into that
man a lot of Star Wars stuff and the
good battlefront games yeah yeah that's
a good that's a blast from the past I
don't have time to play any of those
games cuz I got to play new games but I
might make some time for code or two
yeah yeah that's dope this is really
cool to see because for me xbox was kind
of my the original xbox was my way to
get into PC gaming because a lot of the
games I wanted to play on it the reason
why I wanted again Xbox as a kid is
because they had so many PC ports mm-hmm
and Abba was too broke to get a PC and
even have internet back then so then
yeah around like 2002 do is I get an
Xbox so I could play like upcoming Tom
Clancy games I could play Halo or other
stuff that was essentially not on ps2 or
GameCube those type of games so yeah
this is a Xbox original Xbox is better
than you think it was yeah it still
holds up to this day mm-hmm and you know
what on that note we have more Xbox news
this is about the Xbox 360 which I'm
gonna jump a generation ahead we show a
handful of Xbox 360 games including Red
Dead Redemption are getting updates for
Xbox one X yeah this is pretty dope so
the games that are not just Red Dead
Redemption although it's the most
notable one we will also have Gears of
War 2 portal 2
Darksiders and Star Wars the V force on
force the Force Unleashed yeah so yeah
that's foot 5 I think I can count
correct you did count that correctly
Matt Paget who helps us with our our
notes gets us going in the morning
he notes that the Darksiders
enhancements are cool because THQ Nordic
already released a remastered version on
Xbox one called the war mastered edition
ok um but so this is just an enhanced
version of the original so I'm
interested to see what the difference is
between those are but yeah they'll be
all of those games will be running at a
higher resolution and feature other
visual improvements when you're on an
Xbox one x if you have one of those yeah
which is funny because if you're
watching
live we had that pre-show of our new
game show versus where they were arguing
Xbox versus ps4 and Lucy was all on the
Xbox one X train sleek sleek box
it really is yeah have one or desk they
were talking about which one's more
aerodynamic Oscar was right it's got the
slant the 360 though is another stories
so many great games on the 360 including
Red Dead Redemption and yesterday we was
I was so this footage you're watching
right now we were watching I was
watching Jake captured this and I
remember as great as the Red Dead
Redemption was and like as you know as
great as that world is built it was
really fuzzy because it was a late 360
it was late in a generation so it was
pretty much held back by the hardware
but that game was it was pretty blurry I
play on ps3 and I was like oh man I wish
this ran a little bit better yeah so we
roll I was watching him play the 1x
version Wow let's crispy oh like getting
red dead redemption 4k looks it's it's
real nice of course it's not going to
upgrade any textures character models
lighting or shadows but the bumpin
resolution does make it make the game
like very clear very much playable I
think more playable in the modern era
that game still holds up man john
marston story is something and it's
perfect timing because you do want to
revisit this game before Red Dead 2
comes out because redemption 2 comes out
because I don't know I feel like I like
to revisit games before their sequels
come out I don't know if that's just
like a me thing I have a bad memory for
stories oh I'm like what happened in
that game I played it played last week I
don't remember so that's one of us sorry
I like to read Flag aims because I'm
kind of an idiot anyway the updates are
done using a method called the Hutchy
method i'm not i think that's pronounced
touchy it's named after Microsoft
engineer Eric hachi who developed it
this just a fun fact for you
and lead program manager bill Stillwell
says that it leverages the power of X
Box 1 X to let the Xbox 360 emulator
present the very best version of the
game possible with the existing assets
all without touching the game code cool
that's pretty cool
yes so yeah this game is looking real
crispy and with RTR 2 coming out in whoo
what dude I don't know if I remember the
release date is it October this year
[Music]
October or November shame on us for not
remembering the biggest one of the
biggest release dates of the year yeah
me too
man I keep telling my friends I can't
think they trying to plan trips like and
for the summer I'm like hell I'm even
thinking about like anyway please excuse
us for that but thankfully you can dip
back into a Red Dead Redemption or play
Red Dead Redemption for the first time
on the Xbox one X and all of its new
glory
yeah oh yeah do the work here's war -
he's pretty cool for school and
portal-to-portal smile I mean no it's
it's awesome portal 2 is I played on PC
so I played on xbox so I can dig that up
yeah whatever
cool so that's your your double header
up xbox news you're welcome you're
welcome
single comments or who wanted more X ok
we do love you we do what we can okay
now PC news Steam privacy changes just
killed steam spy this is from PC gamer
steam spy if you don't know well you
know but you don't know gathers public
data to estimate the number of games
sold on steam and steam just added new
options for displaying what games you
own your wish list your play times all
of that so you can it's good for you if
you're interested in privacy mm-hmm so
yeah but you you you know tech all are
you damn oh man
game zone are now hidden by default
which means team spy can't see them like
you said fixable if users make their
games visible so
yes steam spy is really helpful for us I
think in getting a gauge of what people
are playing on Steam totally like
curation of of data so if you uh if
you're one of if you're someone who's
very concerned about their privacy in
all sorts of ways I guess yeah like you
said this is better for you but I mean
yeah this is it is what it is yeah it's
I don't know it sucks for yet like you
said it's not as fun for us because I
mean we like data we like data give us
your data please date you know data
farming and such has been in the news
lately and the least so I think that
privacy options for users is a good
thing and it's nice to have options
mm-hmm so yeah well just be aware like
they were watching a steam controller
yeah yeah I actually was using a steam
controller not too long ago okay I have
to play doom the new doom 2016 and man
it's it's not quite there I was super
sold I was I played portal to actually
going back to talking about portal 2 I
played that with the steam controller I
was like okay this is kind of cool this
makes sense of course there's no real
combat in that game so I was it wasn't
that big a deal but when I'm playing
like doom super fast pace like I don't
know I ain't feeling steam controller
and now many other people have divided
feelings about the steam controller why
are we talking about the steam
controller that's what they're our
b-roll was alright thank you for that
then then lastly we got some ps4 related
news to round it out mhm
we don't discriminate around here god of
war lets you turn off most of the HUD
yeah that's cool that's what's up
yeah so God of War gives a few options
for how much HUD is on the screen
there's - like modes so immersion mode
shows just the minimal absolute
necessary HUD elements that's nice
cool yeah and you can also individually
toggle elements like the compass and
health bars and without the HUD you'll
have to pay more attention to visual
audio cues and I think I laid some gotta
for myself at an at an event mm-hmm
and I very much feel like you can
definitely play this game without a HUD
and you're not gonna really miss out on
much because if because of like this is
playing almost like a half I'm gonna say
it like Dark Souls like people have been
playing God of War like for a while now
because we all get like early copies and
stuff so I'm sure there are people out
there who have said that but it's very
much about recognizing enemy attack
patterns yeah and recognizing when you
when you throw your axe when it comes
back like glut or not glory they're not
called glory kills but they're like doom
glory kills you'll get the visual cue to
do that so this game is very much built
to be able to be played without the hood
yeah and I like that I I find HUDs
distracting in lots of cases like I
really like the Far Cry adopted the like
Skyrim esque
like top bar if I'm that way less
obtrusive than a mini-map I'm not a big
Hut person yeah and I used to play a ton
of Call of Duty and when I played
multiplayer I only played hardcore
specifically because I didn't want to
hood down distracted sound too good
right really not but um like I I think
this is cool yeah I like that and I like
that the game design itself can
communicate enough of that to you where
you can you can survive and get along
without with with a minimal hood you oh
you can also set the HUD to only appear
when you tap the touchpad that's pretty
nice yeah like being a [ __ ] oh
that's your oh [ __ ] button yeah pull it
up when he when you need to but I don't
really see a case well I mean there
there may actually there are many cases
in which you would need it but yeah
that's cool to make it super convenient
to bounce between the two right and then
part of that story or this story that we
are currently talking about is also god
of War's
difficulty levels mm-hmm settings so
let's talk about some of the difficulty
settings here we have give me a story
that gives you minimal challenge give me
a balanced experience is what Sony
recommends which is what I played on
because I needed that balanced
experience but if you're if you're a
little bit better than me which you're
which are probably not no I'm just
kidding you also have given me a
challenge which is how
unless forgiving and then finally the
fourth difficulty setting is give me God
for which is for people quote who
wrestled polar bears in their undies all
right that's for me it's not as as
dramatic as the Wolfenstein difficulty
settings or it's like literally
blaskowitz like in a like baby outfit
yeah I like insulting you for playing
uneasy yeah I mean like I don't yeah I
like I like that the easy setting is
give me a story because I think that
especially like I don't know if you're
interested in the story of this game
like that's a cool option to have oh
wait there's some more details about the
polar bear always undies one Kratos as a
weaker enemies are stronger enemy
behavior is as threatening as possible
mm-hmm and the mode can't even be turned
off once you've chosen it um you really
really put yourself in a bind imagine
playing this playing this game getting
halfway through him like okay that was
really hard and then you get to a point
where it's like impossibly difficult
it's like ah damn what did I do to
myself no so you better be prepared for
a long-term commitment no backing out of
that one yeah if you want to do that but
uh yeah this game is very challenging
and the combat is very much more nuanced
than the previous I think than previous
kata for games cuz I I have played them
in the past and I did play this new one
so yeah
there's a there's a lot of features had
that have been going up on God of War
I know soon we're gonna have our review
reviews are coming soon yeah and we're
gonna have some features on God of War
so if you're interested in this game and
during this kind of lull in the year in
terms of big game releases I think this
is probably gonna be the focus for a lot
of people and PlayStation 4 owners so
this is a pretty big deal I think that
the this game is doing something very
special I want to see I want to play
more of it I am so pumped to play this
game I've never played a god of war but
I love Norse mythology specifically I'm
not I'm really like not into Greek and
Roman mythology so like God of War just
never like super captured me this I was
like wait
you're going to like Midgard yeah if I
can let's go
oh so I'm I'm all about that I'm really
excited to play and all the preview
coverage I've seen has been really
intriguing so I'm excited to see
everybody's reviews coming out soon yeah
because this is a very different
direction for God [ __ ] if you're not
familiar with the preview coverage that
has been out there yeah and the the
dynamic between Kratos and at Reyes his
son is gonna be it like many people have
said already it alludes to or it it
reminds me of the Last of Us that sort
of dynamic but he does play a lot bigger
of a role in the combat so he has his
own separate like skill tree to where
you can use him in very different ways
as a support character so there's a lot
of there's a lot of there's they do a
lot with very little in God of War I
think so anything that is weaved into
the skill trees and tray us as a
companion are they're very fine-tuned in
my opinion from what I have played now I
only like played a preview event for
about like three hours three hours is a
good chunk of time for a preview event
though a lot of times pre-flight I don't
know I played games for preview where I
only got to play like 15 to 30 minutes
oh it's not really yeah okay so three
hours is a I mean obviously you're not
like evaluating the game but to get a
good impression of like oh here's where
what direction this is going in so the
war does some things to say put that on
the Box a little box quote yeah can you
spot god of war it does some things you
heard of here first
don't call now yeah we will have a lot
of stuff for that game yep coming very
soon so stick around the game spot for
that yeah anyway so we we did when we
set out to do which means we can talk
about anime really fast oh we got a we
got about four four minutes before we
got up before we got booted so uh
welcome so we Wednesday will you be
Wednesday so I watched the first episode
of the persona 5 anime last night
it's airing on Saturdays on crunchyroll
and Hulu yeah 10 o'clock is Saturday
morning yeah so if you're interested the
next episode will be up this weekend but
it just covers like the first I want to
say like what
what amounts to the first hour of the
game and I think it will moved really
quickly it has to the show has that game
is 100 hours long and the show is I
think they have 12 episodes for it right
now sometimes they do another 12
episodes for these kind of I think it's
gonna do four they're going for 24 yeah
yeah in anime and instead of like
seasons or whatever they call it curse
and it's whole thing yeah but I don't
know I I thought the animation was
smooth mm-hmm
it looks it looks nice a lot of stuff
moved really quickly but like in a
stylish way yeah I am the hearing the
music from the game I was like yes for
me as well I was like ah yeah gummy and
this personify the animation got me in
my feelings like real talk
and also there's in in the game in
persona 5 there are persona 4 references
so they laid the those on first first
and four in the first eight minutes
they're already alluded to like girl
catchy is say yeah there were little
hints like extra things that aren't in
the game there's like the teacher what's
her name again couple coming yeah coming
she like something fell out of her yeah
bag which alludes to her social link yes
confidant sorry yeah and yeah it's kind
of like I it seems like definitely more
geared towards people who have already
played the game rather than like as a
substitute for playing the game oh yeah
my impression but maybe we'll do
something more with that yeah I I want
to do something more with it because I
think there's a lot there's a lot there
for both people who have played the game
and who have not oh yeah like I was
saying there was some persona for
references Rhys a it was on a billboard
cuz she is a very popular Idol more so
than she was in persona 4 and when in
the opening scene when when the main
character is on on the train they're
watching like these two girls are
watching on their phone they're watching
a girl kechi who is the genius detective
persona 5 they like oh he's the
successor to a naoto shirogane II which
is a character when you're when your
homegirls in persona 4 who was the the
genius detective they're like oh and
shout out to all my homies and
yeah call it and then I also watched a
show from last season that's finished
now but I didn't have a chance to watch
it called how to keep a mummy which is
just about a really cute little like
tiny mummy it's really cute and like the
characters look like classic not classic
anime but they look like mid-2000s anime
characters like it's more of an older
style at least to the like people and so
it kind of just reminded me of maybe
something I'd I'd have watched in middle
school and so I was just like all warm
and fuzzy and I had a nice time watching
yeah well real quick last night I
finished my hero academia season one oh
my god where did you start it I started
it last week or yeah I saw her last
weekend man I was blazing through that I
really liked yeah I liked it a lot I'm
sure um I'm definitely not alone in that
I like cross the board I people love my
hero academia and it was our number one
anime of the Year last year Oh was it
yeah we got some season 2 was I know
tomorrow
gadge will will and Erte is also be a
read the manga - oh snap
ok yeah I was this is giving me a lot of
vibes that I liked from Naruto and I
know the creator of my hair - academia
who said that I drew a lot of influences
from the Creator up Naruto and I
definitely at those vibes and sermon
like the superhero thing instead of
being ninjas or superheroes but man this
every episode that is like uh Midori is
always crying and stuff but it's always
like man it got me in my feelings - man
I really like it - really feel good show
yeah so yeah alright anyway so that's
that's us that's our Wednesday show
happy Wednesday yeah you know we didn't
do that's Wednesday my dudes dance oh
well anyway thank you to our dudes to
all of our dudes so that would be Matt
Padgett Tony Wilson
Emily Conte Chris Pereira Erik Tay
getting us off the ground yes this
morning thank you so much to the people
we work with and thank you so much to
all of you who chill with us to talk
about games and all the hottest gaming
news of the day so yeah
yeah and anime hello if you if you want
that stay tuned if you don't want that
still stay tuned stay tuned for more
radical Heights gameplay oh yes
so right after this your life in one
minute or even sooner
radical Heights stream here on gays
wants to stick around have fun have a
good day good bye bye bye